jeden dezember quälen wir uns mit diesem
sperrigen stachel ding ab und hängen
tonnenweise bling bling und glitzer zeug
dran
tannenbaum alptraum
wer hat diesen monster kitsch bloß
erfunden jedes jahr schauen wir diesem
ungetüm in der stube dann beim sterben
zu wofür brauchen wir einen christbaum
der tannenbaum die palme der lorbeer
schon die ägypter sahen im immergrünen
pflanzen das symbol für lebenskraft zur
wintersonnenwende schmückten sie ihre
häuser mit ihren zweigen als appell an
die götter für eine reichhaltige end
daher stammt der brauch die immergrüne
thale zu schmücken
als weihnachtsbaum kennt man ihn seit
dem mittelalter seinen siegeszug trat er
jedoch erst im 19 jahrhundert
dann halt baum kaufen
rein ins getümmel geschenke kaufen durch
die stadt hetzen drängeln mehr geschenke
essen kommt noch mehr geschenke kaufen
verwandte einladen mit anderen worten
weihnachten feiern
christin und ich glaube geburt christi
es ist also nicht das wort und ich
glaube er ist für mich einfach alles
erfinden zum status quo wird sagt wir
jetzt mit religiöser grenzen
sozialisiert wurde alles halt nur
schenken also irgendwas ja größer teurer
besser dass jesus am 25 dezember zur
welt gekommen sein sollte wurde
nachträglich konstruiert
die noch junge christliche kirche
vereinnahmte so das populäre fest der
wintersonnenwende
der geschenke bringen der weihnachtsmann
hingegen geht auf den heiligen nikolaus
zurück der bringt den kindern seine
gaben anfang dezember erst die
reformatoren die den heiligen kult
bekämpften verschoben die beschädigung
auf weihnachten und das christkind
anfangs des zwanzigsten jahrhundert sind
stand dann das säkularisierte du bild
des heiligen nikolaus der weihnachtsmann
der ist heute für alle kapriolen zu
haben und kommt als samichlaus und santa
clause gleich zweimal im jahr
die kleinen schrauben so doppelt ab und
die groß bleibt von den alten bräuchen
nur noch das profane bechern
wenn der baum richtig zu brennen beginnt
hilft nur der bereitgestellte mit wasser
gefüllten eimer ja dann auch die letzte
mühsal die entsorgung niedrigste
fronarbeit einzig die skandinavier
gewinnen dem noch eine spaßige seite ab
sie feiern lud das fest der reinigung
na dann die welt belegt
frohes fest